you're you're scratching at the surface
of what my biggest complaint and fear is
i am not surprised that the government
exercised the dictatorial powers
because the the government doesn't care
about human liberty it just cares about
power and staying in power and if the
government can give the impression that
it's doing something it will stay in
power what has crushed me and broken my
heart
is how americans accepted this
how we laid down and allowed them to
close churches
to close schools well the government
owns the schools but to interfere
with freedom of travel with freedom of
assembly
even with freedom of speech not far from
where i am now in this
beautiful a countrified area on palm
sunday two palm sundays ago
a catholic priest was distributing palms
wrapped in cellophane
outdoors to people in their cars
and the state police broke it up the
cars were too close to each other and
they were too close to this priest as he
physically handed them the palms wrapped
in cellophane and i went uh berserk on
air and
in in my writings because the governor
who ordered this
appeared at a black lives matter uh
rally and i the part of the black lives
matter that i think is absolutely
legitimate there were three thousand
people there they weren't masked and he
was the featured speaker so this is an
example of the government using
power to promote its own power and the
american public accepted it
all right so let's move on to uh to
russia because you've taken the position
uh that i i fully respect because it's
hard to get any
sort of sense out of what's going on
with russia and ukraine that that
sanctions
actually violate the constitution
so can you explain that a bit
sure
and this is not anti uh joe biden i
honestly believe he's doing everything
he can
short of war
to resist putin
i also believe that putin's ultimately
going to win and that by our arming the
ukrainians we're probably making it
worse
bloodier and more deadly
however however
the sanctions fall into three categories
seizing assets
freezing
assets
and interfering with contracts
so under the fourth amendment if the
government freezes a bank account
they've reached your bank account for
example you can't take any money out
that's a seizure
and under the fourth amendment the
government can only seize something with
a search warrant
after they demonstrate to a judge like i
was assigned hundreds of these
uh probable cause of crime
so if they seize your yacht in the bay
of naples if the carabinieri which is
the italian version of the fbi seizes
your yacht in the bay of naples and they
won't let you on it and they've sent it
to port newark so that the feds can
actually own it and sell it
they have seized your property illegally
if they've frozen your bank account
without a search warrant they are frozen
your bank account illegally
if they have interfered with lawful
commercial transactions if for example
you're an importer of stolich naya vodka
and you've paid for a cargo ship full of
stolich naya and it arrives at port
newark or chicago or detroit and the
feds send it away
well then the the feds have interfered
with your lawful commercial transactions
the fifth amendment says if the
government wants life liberty
contractual rights or property income
from the contract they have to have a
jury trial at which fault is proven now
under what basis is president biden
engaging in these sanctions there's two
statutes dave
that the feds enacted
one is the international economic
emergency act of 1977 carter era
one is the magnitsky act of 2016
obama era both of these statutes allow
the president
without any evidence or judicial process
whatsoever
to declare a human being or an entity
foreign human being or foreign entity
a violator of human rights
and seize their assets
and if they want the assets back if
you're this billionaire whose yacht was
stolen by the carabinieri and you want
it back you have to come to america
submit to the federal court jurisdiction
which they're never going to do because
they're afraid they'll get arrested for
some trumped-up charge and then you have
to prove that you're not
a human rights violator how do you prove
a negative
and that's alice in wonderland you're in
a federal court the government wants
your property and you have to prove that
you're not what they say you are forget
about it the government has the burden
of proof the person whose life liberty
or property the government wants always
is presumed
innocent and to presume to be the valid
owner of the life liberty or property
so this these two statutes which have
not been challenged constitutionally
because these foreigners are not going
to come here to challenge them
give the president dictatorial powers
which he has exercised
why do you think some of our companies
maybe that do business with russia say
i'll use the example that you gave i
mean you're just a an american company
who's a vodka importer who's now your
business in essence has been destroyed i
mean should they be suing the federal
government at this point yes they should
yeah
yes they yeah they should look the
government
i don't know what you think of this
phrase the government loves to hate
i like it okay so for
200 years the federal government hated
black people either as slaves or under
jim crow
the federal government told us to hate
the soviet union and then hate iran and
then hate iraq and then hate saddam
hussein and then pardon this hate
coveted now it's hate putin and hate all
things russian well the russian people
have nothing to do with this they have
the misfortune of being being uh
governed by a
a dictator i don't think he's crazy i
think he's perfectly rational but he
doesn't care about human liberty or
about human life and innocent people are
are being punished
are being harmed
the the ruble buys about five percent
today
of what it bought a month ago so you're
paying 15
for a loaf of bread that should have
cost a dollar fifty
yeah absolutely incredible i i hope some
of these companies fight that i mean
because that's where people forget these
are we're now punishing americans these
are these are americans who just
happened to do business with something
that perhaps originated in russia uh
let's move to kovit because you've hit
it a couple times here i mean
i'm pretty sure that anything you're
going to say on the covet front i agree
with you i think our civil liberties
have been destroyed as you know i fled
california just in the last couple
months i now live in the free state of
florida because i could not deal with
the lockdowns and the mass mandates and
the general state of depression that it
brought and all of the closed businesses
and the dreams that were shattered and
the whole freaking thing
however we've still got masks on planes
uh they've still got masks on you know
three-year-olds in in you know toddlers
yet joe biden can give the state of the
union with a bunch of 80 year olds in a
room with no windows and that's okay
what do you make of the entire freaking
thing was this just a disaster from you
know we're basically at the two-year
anniversary two years ago
should we have been all screaming louder
and and known what was coming okay so
you're you're you're scratching at the
surface of what my biggest complaint and
fear is i am not surprised that the
government exercised the dictatorial
powers
because the the government doesn't care
about human liberty it just cares about
power and staying in power and if the
government can give the impression that
it's doing something it will stay in
power what has crushed me and broken my
heart
is how americans accepted this
how we laid down and allowed them
to close churches
to close schools well the government
owns the schools but to interfere with
freedom of travel with freedom of
assembly
even with freedom of speech i mean not
far from where i am now in this
beautiful a countrified area on palm
sunday two palm sundays ago
a catholic priest was distributing palms
wrapped in cellophane
outdoors to people in their cars
and the state police broke it up
the cars were too close to each other
and they were too close to this priest
as he physically handed them the palms
wrapped in cellophane and i went uh
berserk on air and
in in my writings because the governor
who ordered this
appeared at a black lives matter uh
rally and i they're part of the black
lives matter that i think is absolutely
legitimate there were three thousand
people there they weren't masked and he
was the featured speaker
so this is an example of the government
using
power to promote its own power and the
american public accepted it
um i once had an argument with roger
ailes about whether
a dictator could ever take over in the
united states and he took the position
it wouldn't that the public would never
stand for it
well when the public is afraid the
government's weapon was fear
we became a nation of sheep
and we still are
because governor murphy of
new jersey governor whitmer of michigan
former governor cuomo of new york that
mentality could come back in a week if
some unnamed variant of covid kicks in
again if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversation about law
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our law
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell